les bruyères divers tapissent encore le
sol des sous-bois cerisiers en fleurs
commencent à dévoiler toute sa splendeur
l'arboretum d'un gran a revêtu ses
habits de printemps les visiteurs sont
sous le charme on connaissait pas du
tout cet endroit est là vraiment on est
surpris de trouver ça et déjà quelques
fleurs qui commence à pointer le bout de
leur nez et puis je pense que d'ici un
ou deux mois ça serait encore plus beau
un endroit apaisant c'est très
silencieux comparé à d'autres parc en
bord de route
le parc a profité de quatre mois et demi
de fermeture pour se refaire une beauté
dans la partie asiatique la forêt à
reculer pour laisser place à un nouveau
parterre de plantes on a donc coupé
quelques heures où évidemment quelques
quelques boulots et on a la place planté
des armes de collection donc là toutes
les armes que vous voyez et qui ont une
sorte de qui on vote avec tout ça ce
sont des nouvelles plantations de cette
année on a créé le chemin donc on est en
train de prendre là tout ça n'existait
pas des aménagements destinés à faire la
part belle aux arbres en pépinière mais
toujours pensé dans le respect de
l'harmonie des lieux un boulot qui qui
tranche derrière le conifère qui est
noir c'est beaucoup plus beau on voit le
boulot c'est quand même très très joli
ça vaut la peine inde on met des choses
en valeur ce qu'on veut important est
important
que les gens puissent se voir salle et
est heureux
le mois prochain les magnolias en fleurs
seront l'objet de toutes les attentions
à l'occasion d'un concours photo
organisé sur les réseaux sociaux